Tier lists have been a staple of YouTube for
a few years now, at this point, you can find
a ranking of just about anything.
TierZoo was the first channel I saw to combine
the format with science and learning.
But it's already spread into physics and maths
as well.
For example, Andrew Dotson recently did a
ranking of his favourite physics equations.
Today, I thought it would be time to create
an ultimate mathematical shapes tier list.
I've got a non rigorous point system to give
each shape a fair chance at that coveted S-tier
position.
So each object will be judged on symmetry,
singularities, the significance in other disciplines
outside of mathematics, how difficult it is
to define or create and the aesthetics.
For aesthetics, we're really asking, does
this shape deserve its own mood board on Pinterest.
Now, that's of course going to be subjective,
but it's worth including aesthetics as a criteria,
because it's kind of important to math.
The beauty of the shape may indicate that
we've got some kind of elegant solution, or
at least to help inspire interest in the topic.
So let's start with a nice simple shape, the
common sphere, I'll be using the software
SURFER to model some of these shapes.
This algebraic surface is as old as it gets,
it is perfectly symmetric, which makes it
awesome to work with.
But at the same time, it might be a bit boring
and uninspiring because it looks the same
in all directions.
However, this hasn't stopped the sphere from
becoming a major player in other disciplines.
You see it in art and sports and engineering
all the time.
And even in astrophysics for things like planets,
and even black holes.
Spheres are very effective for modelling all
sorts of things.
Probably because the sphere is very easy to
understand.
Aesthetics wise, the sphere might not be the
most interesting shape.
But because of its heroic performance in all
sorts of disciplines, and how easy it is to
construct, I think that B-tier is more than
deserved.
Next up is another classic, the Mobius strip.
It's a two dimensional object with only one
side and one edge that can be embedded in
a three dimensional space.
There are no notable things to say about it
symmetry or singularities.
But just like with the sphere, where a mobius
strip shines is in its applications to other
disciplines.
Surprisingly, there are actually some applications
of this strange little shape.
One of them is that in the days of industrialization,
a lot of factories had one central engine
to provide rotational energy to operate all
the machines, a common thing was to use flat
leather belts to transmit the central power.
Some were instead given a half twist before
joining the ends and this would allow for
the wear to be evenly distributed over both
sides of the belt.
You can make a mobius strip pretty easily
yourself, just take a long piece of paper,
give it a twist and glue the ends together.
If you start at any point and draw along the
strip, you end up we started.
In mathematics, we call the shape with a property
like this non orientable.
Since you can't really define an up or down
on a surface like this.
I think the simplicity of being able to create
such an interesting shape makes it very intriguing
and worthy of an A-tier spot.
Now this next crazy critter is the Barth Sextic,
which I recently made an entire video about.
It's going to belong in S-tier because it's
got very interesting symmetry, record breaking
singularities and an intriguing history.
It is one of the world record surfaces since
it holds the record for having the largest
number of singularities for a polynomial of
degree six, that record that it holds is 65
singularities.
And it was proven that it can never be beaten,
that 66 singularities isn't possible.
Now there are some other members of the world
record squad and they ought to join it in
here as well.
So we have the Togliatti Quintic, which holds
the record for a polynomial of degree five,
and that record is 31 singularities.
I think they belong one tier below the Barth
Sextic since the record is for a lower degree.
Then Likewise, we have the Kummer Quartic,
which holds the record for a polynomial of
degree four.
And that record it holds is 16 singularities.
I'll put that one in B-tier, and then we'll
have the Kayley Cubic, another world record
surface, this time of degree three, coming
in with four singularities, and getting placed
in C-tier.
The next one is also a record holder, it's
the double cone coming in with one singularity,
for degree two.
I talked about this one a bit as well in my
video about the Barth Sextic, you can really
see that prominent singularity in the middle
of the shape.
This shape is also quite interesting in special
relativity in physics, as you might have seen
it in something called a light cone.
It shows the causal future and the past.
You can think of the singularity in the middle
as an event in space time, and all other events
inside the double cone can have a causal relationship
with that first event, everything outside
the cone would be too far away to have any
impact, or to be impacted by the original
event in space time.
And this angle of the cone is governed by
the speed of light.
That's a very interesting application but
because the record this one holds is not as
impressive as some of the other records we've
seen, it's going to sit in C-tier.
And now I've got two more shapes to quickly
mention here, which also currently hold world
records but perhaps not for long.
These are the Labs-Septic, and the Endrass-Octic.
These currently hold records for seven and
eighth degree polynomials.
Although these records haven't been proven
to be unbeatable in the way that our other
record holders were.
For the Barth Sextic, we've proven that you
can never have more than 65 singularities.
But here for the septic, and this optic, it's
very feasible that someone might be able to
find a shape which will beat it.
For that reason, they're both going to be
banished to D-tier.
Let's see what we can do next, we have Gauss
Bell surface.
The surface might look unspectacular at first,
since there are no interesting points that
really stand out, no singularities.
But don't underestimate this gem of mathematics.
It is used all the time in statistics and
is the foundation of the normal distribution.
Furthermore, what's very interesting is that
the formula defining the surface shows a really
nice connection between the fundamental constants
pi and e.
This one is difficult to rank because the
aesthetics are lacking a bit and the competition
is harsh, but we'll place them here in C-tier.
Next up, we can do the Torus, or you might
like to call it a doughnut.
It is a rotational symmetric shape of genus
one, since it has one hole, and this shape
is often brought up when talking about the
topic of topology.
Everything with one hole is said to be topologically
equivalent to a Torus, and the classic example
is a coffee mug with a handle or drinking
straw.
Of course, its applications are very wide
from hair ties, to rings, to edible donuts,
or even pool toys.
It has vast applications and because of that,
we're going to put it in B-tier.
Next we have a shape which is a close relative
of one that we've already seen.
This is the Klein bottle, and it's very similar
to the Mobius strip since both surfaces are
non orientable.
The Klein bottle also has only one surface
but unlike the strip, the two dimensional
bottle can't be embedded in three dimensions,
it always looks like it intersects itself,
when in reality, it doesn't.
You might have noticed this shape in my profile
picture here on YouTube.
The beanie that I wear is actually a Klein
bottle hat that I made by knitting it.
Although of course, it's not an accurate Klein
bottle since that can't exist in 3D.
If you see the way it intersects, that wouldn't
happen if we had the luxury of a fourth spatial
dimension.
Unfortunately, making nice hats and glass
bottles might be the limit of applications
that I know about the Klein bottle to the
world outside mathematics.
But the Klein bottle definitely deserves to
be ranked alongside the Mobius strip up here
and A-tier.
Especially because if you actually were to
split a Klein bottle in half, what you would
have would be two Mobius strips.
This little twisty boy is called the Trefoil
knot qnd it does seem to be the poster child
for knot theory.
It is named after the three leaf clover, the
Trefoil plant and it has some nice triangular
sort of symmetry to it.
The knot is one continuous loop and easy enough
to make yourself using a string.
I also happened to have this sculpture lying
around, which is another example of this kind
of knot.
So clearly, it's gonna rank pretty high on
aesthetics, if they're literally selling it
as a decoration.
I don't have a great deal of knowledge about
knot theory but apparently this is the first
non trivial knot.
And one of the reasons why knot theory is
so interesting is that it seems to have many
applications in biology and chemistry with
things like proteins and DNA that are knotted
in some sense.
I'm going to rank it in B-tier for now, it's
got some points for aesthetics, some points
for a possible usefulness even though I might
not totally understand how this note is useful,
but it is still a fairly basic shape.
We're back to a heavy hitter with the next
one, Flamm's paraboloid.
This one's going to get ranked right up at
S-tier.
It doesn't perhaps look that spectacular,
but it is pretty cool.
This shape mimics the outside of a black hole
in the space time called the Schwarzschild
solution.
In 1915 when Einstein published his famous
field equations of general relativity, he
didn't actually solve them himself.
Instead, a German scientist named Karl Schwarzschild
found the first interesting solution in relativity,
a spacetime containing a black hole.
He calculated this while he was stationed
in Russia during the First World War.
And sadly, he died not long after his groundbreaking
discovery.
He calculated that spacetime stops behaving
normal at some radius, this is the inner circle
in the middle, now, we call this the event
horizon.
The surface shows how everything gets attracted
to that circle, and what happens beyond this
point is anyone's guess at the moment.
It is amazing to see how clearly general relativity
predicted the existence of black holes like
this, when no one could imagine this before.
This is a cornerstone of science wrapped up
in one picture and that's why it deserves
to be in S-tier.
Second to last, here we have the dodecahedron.
Now, this is supposed to represent all five
of the platonic solids.
We've all seen them before, and they're so
iconic that they definitely deserve to be
ranked here.
All of these solids have some very special
symmetry to them.
And in fact, these solids define what symmetries
other shapes can have.
For example, back in my Barth Sextic video,
it was the symmetry of the icosahedron that
allowed us to get that shape.
What makes the platonic solids so special
is the uniqueness they have.
These shapes are the only options if you want
a polyhedron with identical faces and corners.
And the fact that there are only five seems
quite surprising.
You see these shapes, of course, a lot in
architecture, or anywhere really throughout
history.
And so considering this A-tier is a fitting
spot.
And this list would of course, not be complete
without at least one fractal.
I've chosen to include the Mandelbrot set.
This relatively new shape finds its home in
complex analysis, and is known for its crazy
boundary.
It is one of those fractals which are inherently
self similar.
Meaning that you can zoom in on the border
as much as you want and would always end up
with the same thing on screen.
There isn't too much to talk about in terms
of symmetry, and singularities with this one.
And I'm not sure about any usefulness in other
scientific fields, but it is used a lot in
art.
And as I'm sure you can imagine, or might
have seen, there are plenty of nice, psychedelic
like zooming videos using this shape, plenty
of which you can watch here on YouTube.
The construction of this shape is surprisingly
simple.
And I'm going to explore it using Brilliant
who are also a sponsor of this video and have
been a huge supporter of my channel.
I do really like their explanation and a lot
of their visuals for the Mandelbrot set.
So let's have a look at how they say we can
define it, what you do is you start with a
complex number, call it z, then if you square
that and add it to itself, look at what you
end up with, then square that and add z to
that and keep going like that forever.
You'll notice that one of two things would
happen; either the magnitude explodes up towards
infinity, and in that case, the complex number
z is not in the Mandelbrot set.
If the magnitude is bounded or tends towards
zero, then the numbers z is in the Mandelbrot
set.
We can ask ourselves is the complex number
i in the set?
Well, it is because after the first few iterations,
we would have i, then minus one plus i, then
minus i, then back to minus one plus i.
And this set of answers will repeat, we're
in a bit of an alternating cycle.
And since we're not going to end up going
out to infinity, the value of i is in the
Mandelbrot set, so it will be plotted somewhere
on that interesting picture.
Another example is the real number one.
With that we would have one, then two, then
five, then 26.
And because each time we're squaring that
answer and adding one to it, we're just going
to keep getting larger and larger until we
get to infinity.
So one is not in the Mandelbrot set.
Another couple of examples here we have that
minus two is in the Mandelbrot set, whilst
minus two i is not.
This here is a full image of the Mandelbrot
set and you can zoom in on parts of the boundary
to see its chaotic nature.
The set has a main cardioid, which is this
heart shaped section here, as well as several
attached bulbs.
And the position of a number within either
the cardioid, or these numbered bulbs here
tells us something about recursion, or I think
the fate of the number, whether it reaches
an equilibrium or a fixed point.
I love looking at this fractal because every
piece of it is loaded with mathematical meaning.
And one of the reasons that it might be so
appealing is because you get such a complicated
surface with a relatively easy mathematical
construction.
To this date, there are still plenty of open
questions surrounding the set and it has led
to the discovery of many equally astounding
shapes, such as the Mandelbulb, or the Buddhabrot.
It is pretty legendary so I'm going to put
it up in S-tier.
Let me know what you think of my ranking.
I'm sure there will be some that you disagree
with but it's just for fun.
And I'm sure there's also some interesting
shapes that I've left out, because how could
I include all of them in one video, but tell
me some of those main ones you think should
be included next time.
Thanks to Brilliant for sponsoring this video
and if you're interested to check out their
content a bit more, they have courses on mathematics,
science, including physics, astronomy, computer
science, biology, a lot of interesting stuff,
you can head to brilliant.org/tibees and that
link will be down in the description.
Thanks to my Patreon supporters for making
these videos possible.
And a special shout out to today's Patron
Cat of the Day, Maureen.